a surprise move canadian prime minister
justin trudeau has suspended the
country's parliament
that's despite vowing in the past never
to make use of that power
critics are accusing the canadian leader
of trying to dodge scrutiny over his
government's role
in a growing ethics scandal that also
involves his family
i have asked the governor general to
prorogue parliament
which must happen before any government
can present a throne speech
starting a new session of parliament is
about creating
sustainable ways to support you moving
forward
that has always been our number one
focus and it always will be
justin trudeau amputated his right hand
to try
and save himself when he forced his
finance minister
to resign now he's shutting down
parliament
and locking out and position mps to
prevent us from holding him accountable
and getting answers on his we scandal
shutting down parliament in the middle
of a pandemic and an economic crisis
with a plan sitting next week and
committees working hard to get answers
and solutions for canadians
is wrong trudeau has justified the
five-week suspension with the need to
reassess the parliament's agenda
several of its committees had been
investigating the government's actions
involving a student grant program
canada's independent ethics watchdog is
also separately investigating the prime
minister
trudeau is being probed over alleged
breaches of conflict of interest laws
for awarding a 690 million dollar
student grant program to we charity
which has ties to the pm's relatives
trudeau has dismissed allegations of
preferential treatment
we charity and the government have since
ended their partnership
the prime minister has been reprimanded
by the country's ethics watchdog twice
before
last year he was probed for pressuring
his former attorney general to help a
major canadian company
settle a corruption case out of court
journalist pablo vivenko
says this latest scandal is unlikely to
go away
a number of high-ranking liberals
including the prime minister were
connected with the charity
his family members his mother and his
brother
received close uh over 300 000
in uh paid speaking uh opportunities
with that organization
i i do think that over the last couple
of years
his character has has been damaged by
his own actions by his own words
uh by his past and how that conflicts
with his present
by the things he's saying versus the
things that he's doing
and the the recent use of the probation
as well as the wii scandal
are things which are continuing to mount
to that
i do believe that when there when an
election
does loom in the near future that uh the
liberal party could perhaps be looking
at somebody else to lead it